[Music]
we may not know much about the captain
marvel movie yet
but we do know that this 90s set
superhero adventure will star oscar
winner brie larson as the first female
in the marvel universe to lead her own
standalone film
larson has been hard at work in
hollywood since she was just a kid and
off-screen she's known for being
candidly outspoken and down to earth
it turns out that her real-life story is
just as fascinating as those of the
characters she portrays
humble beginnings larson was very young
when she already knew what she wanted to
do with her life
i told my mom i knew who my dharma was
when i was six years old you knew what
your dharma was
so hippie parents hippie or not her
parents took their daughter's ambitions
seriously and it's easy to understand
why
that year she became the youngest
student ever accepted at san francisco's
american conservatory theater
larson's mother soon relocated the
aspiring actress and her younger sister
to los angeles where the trio squeezed
into a tiny furnished
studio apartment and larson started
auditioning of her mother's support
larson told elle
my mom always felt like she was a
creative person and her parents wouldn't
allow her to have that kind of life
so when i got interested in acting she
was like okay let's make this happen
and things did start to happen at the
age of seven she filmed commercial
parodies for the tonight show with jay
leno
thanks roadkill after that larson
started to book small parts on tv shows
including popular and touched by an
angel
awkward teen despite her early successes
larson's career wasn't a straight climb
to the top she faced plenty of rejection
while trying to land her breakout role
it was emotionally taxing for the young
star not to mention the financial toll
it took on her she told the guardian
i'd hit the point where i'd go okay
that's it that's the last dollar i've
gotta quit or go to college or whatever
but that day or the next day something
would happen that would make it
strangely apparent i'm supposed to keep
doing this a bit longer
for larson the turnaround started when
she was cast as kate on united states of
terra and drew critical praise for her
performance as the sardonic teenager by
the time the show was canceled after
three seasons
larson's star was on the rise and
casting directors had started taking
note
you want to take a picture with me bree
versus the world
of all the movies she's made larson has
said there's only one she rewatches
the wacky action comedy scott pilgrim vs
the world unfortunately her turn as
ex-girlfriend envy adams went largely
unnoticed by theater goers during its
2010 release
still things were slowly picking up for
larsen she had better luck in her
supporting role as jonah hill's love
interest in 21 jump street which was not
only critically well received it was a
hit at the box office as well
taking in more than 200 million dollars
worldwide larson garnered praise from
critics as a standout who brought nuance
and depth to a supporting character that
could have been totally unmemorable
dramatic breakthrough she may have been
only 23 when she stepped into her first
leaning role as troubled youth care
worker grace in the 2013
indie drama short term 12 but larson had
been working hard for more than 15 years
by the time she got her first major big
screen break
larson shadowed real workers and did
extensive research to capture grace's
emotions with depth and accuracy
she told new york magazine i was
terrified and excited it was confusing
when we screened the film at the south
by southwest festival for the first time
i had never had people look at me that
way before the film won the narrative
feature award at south by southwest
and larson took home a gotham award at
the end of the year
the lighter side larson isn't all about
drama all the time
2013 also saw a pair of rom-com
supporting roles in the spectacular now
and don john
and in 2015 she charmed audiences with
her comedic chops and amy schumer's
train wreck
playing a fictionalized version of
schumer's sister kim and enduring a very
unusual audition process to land the
part
it all started when director judd apatow
called larsen and invited her to lunch
my agent is like what what happened what
did you do i was like i don't know i
just talked about myself for a while and
i ate a salad and that was sort of van
like what did they want i was like i
don't know
as she tells it larson came back for
lunch every day and soon bill hader
showed up too
apatow eventually filled the actors in
on his plans using the get togethers as
part of his unorthodox casting process
oscar winner after reading emma
donohue's book room in a single day
larson knew she wanted to play the part
of ma the kidnapped teen turned
long-term captive and mother
after beating out several other
actresses for the part larson dove into
the role with a massive amount of prep
work
she avoided the sun to achieve a palette
complexion packed on 15 pounds of lean
muscle
and even stayed home for a month an
experience she admitted was intensely
draining both physically and emotionally
larson's emotionally raw performance in
room was met with near universal acclaim
and earned her the biggest hollywood
accolade of them all an oscar
raising the stakes the claustrophobic
confines of room
were followed with a complete 180 for
larsen when she landed a main role in
2017's kong skull island
shot in vietnam in hawaii it was full of
big everything
big budget big a-list co-stars big
special effects and of course
one very big gorilla while her first
post-oscar performance wasn't received
with the same glowing critical praise as
past roles she was credited with turning
the franchise's traditionally fainting
female lead into a more modern
empowered counterpart to tom
hiddleston's explorer more importantly
kong skull island proved larsen had the
star power to carry a popcorn flick
it was her most successful box office
outing to date taking in 566 million
dollars worldwide
meet captain marvel at comic con 2016
the cast of the marvel universe
assembled on stage for a family photo
and then came a special announcement
brie larson was introduced as captain
marvel a role everyone at marvel takes
seriously you're gonna get the most
powerful superhero that we've ever
that we've ever introduced with i think
one of the most unique and inspiring
origin stories
that's an awful lot of responsibility
for one movie but larson seems eager to
step up to the challenge
she told reporters i'm really proud of
what it is that we're making
i think all the hype and anticipation
will be worth it
looks like a perfect fit